when Alec Baldwin accused of extremely
Reckless acts and rust killing Alec
Baldwin and the former armor on the film
Russ has been charged with involuntary
manslaughter in the fatal shooting of
the film cinematographer according to
court papers filed in the First Judicial
District Court in New Mexico prosecutors
accused Baldwin of nat receiving
sufficient firearm training failing to
handle safety complaints putting his
finger on the trigger of a real firearm
instead of a replica and pointing the
firearm at the cinematographer and
director armorer Hannah Gutierrez Reid
was accused of not checking the rounds
she located loaded the Firearms into
allowing the rounds of the uh on the set
alarm ammunition to not be secured
failing to stay with the firearm and not
being qualified for the armor position
Baldwin has long maintained he is not
responsible for the fatal shooting
prosecutors told Baldwin was culpable
for not checking he was also culpable
for not checking the gun or ensuring
someone else did and for not attending
firearm safety training at uh Vinnie so
and and but mind you I was always a fan
of Alec Baldwin from Hunter Red October
and just all the movies and everything
but this guy showed his true colors um
even before Trump but then during like
all the incidents that he got into in
front of his house in Manhattan with all
the you know yelling at William try to
yell and like get confrontational with
women to all that stuff and this is just
a a a a prime case of just the
narcissist and the hypocrite this guy
went after the NRA talking all this crap
about guns and nobody you know all these
people that are having guns bro the
number one rule with guns is what you
guys know right always treat it as if
it's loaded one 100 he would have known
this if he went to the training because
by the way uh he didn't show up okay to
the actual required firearm training
which you know Mr Mr hypocrite guy when
he showed up he was distracted talking
on the cell phone prosecutors say
there's a photo of him finger on the
trigger acting like you know like like a
[__] like like trying to point at
people and stuff and like I said if he
knew if he went to the training that's
the problem with all these people that
are anti-gun and stuff that hate gun
some if if you're trained on it less
accidents like this happen God forbid
and God Rest The Souls of the people
that passed away but it's always the pot
calling the kettle black all the all the
ones that bark and look at this look at
that like you're the ones that are
actually the idiots you know I mean like
he's he's the [__] if he paid attention
and actually did the training which I
think the majority of Americans should
have some basic training because God
forbid you have to have a gun in your
hand none of this type of [__] would
happen
uh this has been going on for a long
time and so the prosecutors had a time
to talk to everybody and some of this
language that I see from the prosecutor
we're in the insurance industry
um there were three of us here Adam you
are pat you are does some of this
language look kind of like the thing
that uh an adjuster or lost control
would be saying because remember there's
insurance on that set that's going to
have to cover of course the loss that's
going to cover the loss of life there's
Insurance on there to cover lawsuits for
injuries on set it's there's huge you
know we have insurance when value
payment goes off and does uh a field
shoot we have insurance certificate not
attending firearm safety training you
know failing to handle safety complaints
and you know all of this to me sounds
like there's an investigation that's
done here and what happened on that set
was a terrible accident and tragedy and
it can be an accident and a tragedy but
it doesn't take away from the place that
doesn't look like that they did the
appropriate
um you know safety routine and if you've
ever gone and and had gun training and I
have when you're sitting standing there
side by side with someone who's teaching
you about maybe a pistol you're thinking
of buying and you go to a firing range
they always say down and Away down and
away so you point it down away and he
says when I hand it to you you look
and so he says and he goes and he'll say
that's loaded look and so I look and
that's always what they teach you so
that when you receive a firearm I miss
what they did in the military Pat right
don't assume what the guy just told you
is correct down and away and look and
I I think sorry dude Baldwin if there's
pictures of you fooling around there and
you didn't do the safety training you're
sculpable it's a terrible tragedy you
can call it an accident picture culpable
dude when you say culpable I guess we'll
see what happens here like I don't think
anybody thinks that he is going to be
he's not he's not gonna go to jail he
didn't want to murder this person let's
get realized it was not first second
third degree murder I don't know if
manslaughter is going to be the charge
but I think we're losing side this lady
lost her life innocent lady you know why
is the gun even loaded to begin with
with real bullets what the hell is that
all about and then his defensive like I
didn't pull the trigger it's like I
don't know how that works whatever that
defense is but at the end of the day
this is a really sad situation I think
he's going to lose some sort of civil
lawsuit have to pay the family a ton of
money I don't see Alec Baldwin Alex
A-list Hollywood actor going to jail
nothing at all no no no so I think
that's the bottom line no yeah 100 but
it just goes It goes to show you though
got like any gun on could you imagine as
being in Hollywood being on a set even
when they would give you a gun out of
and I'm an ex-military cop always away
never and dude I'm pretty sure every guy
we all know this if you got a fake gun
that you think is not loaded you're
doing Quick Draw McGraw you're acting
like a cowboy and then boom tragic but
they could have been avoided to your
point Adam that's what I call it it's a
terrible tragedy a tragedy that came out
of an accident but it was an avoidable
accident and on set you know the
culpability goes to he's not going to go
to jail but there's Insurance here and
there's you know settlements and there's
things like that kind of the ugly side
of this and um it does it doesn't bring
back a A Gifted filmmaker it's
unfortunate look I I don't care if the
the person is uh uh agrees with me
disagrees with me we're on the same page
we're not on the same page you're on the
team you're not on the team nobody wants
to see a story like this because an
innocent person was killed on the set
and this guy's life is ruined I mean you
know Alec messed up his life for being
arrogant foolish and not being
responsible for it it's just something
that it happens to everybody but there
isn't anything that's a higher level
than this you took someone's life so uh
uh you know how much of that
responsibility is on him how much are
the responsibility on the other guy why
the hell do you have a real weapon
loaded weapon on the set anyways like as
an actor I'm assuming the actor's
already thinking about doing their part
their role like what else you want me to
also so I don't know maybe the funding
they didn't have enough funding for they
were too cheap in that area that they
didn't want to make that investment who
knows but you're dealing with an
a-lister so you know anyways what are
you doing taking a movie I don't know
what Alec Baldwin is worth why are you
taking how much money were they paying
you to be on a set that's being cheap
about it there's so many questions I
have but it's not my job it's the it's
the juries and the judge's job to make
that decision did they finish the movie
Pat do you know if they actually
wouldn't even tell forward with them
first of all Imagine That movie oh my
God this is the movie would you want to
go watch the movie like that maybe you
know it's like one of those uh I don't
know dude that's pretty crazy yeah
filming uh resume yeah they they're okay
dude what a awkward because mind you bro
if there's guns in that scene there's
guns throughout the whole damn movie
it's like I was like I wouldn't I'd be
like nobody even touched this guy we're
gonna put like a fake gun in your hand
we don't want anybody pointing or doing
anything well let's listen this is a uh
uh again we'll see what happened here at
this point it's the chance like Adam
says your chance of somebody like him
and A-list are going to jail like Kevin
Spacey you're seeing that stuff it's uh
probably not likely he'll have to pay
but we'll see what happens next so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast test
click right here
[Music]